germany now has some of the world's
strictest rules for people who are not
fully vaccinated against covet 19.
the country also has a vocal minority
who refuse to get the jab
many subscribe to conspiracy theories
and call themselves queer dankers or
transgressive thinkers
they've been protesting against the
increasing rules in germany and now many
are so fed up they're leaving
some anti-vaxxers are now looking to get
away from the lockdowns and restrictions
of their homeland
even to places as far off as south
america
[Music]
hello and welcome to deutsche welle's
coveted 19 special i'm stephen beardsley
in berlin
with every wave of copper 19 illnesses
in germany comes a new backlash from
those strongly opposed to the health
measures taken in response including
vaccination
protests and refusal to wear masks in
public places are the actions that most
commonly take
some however have gone to more extreme
measures
olga and volacon came to hohenau in
december 2020. it's a small town with
around 15 000 inhabitants in the south
of paraguay
it was founded in 1900 by german
settlers
the cones appreciate the peace and quiet
here in the countryside
the corns emigrated from stuttgart in
southwestern germany to paraguay
together with vola's brother and his
wife they say they can lead a free life
here without covet restrictions
staying healthy for many more years
we have more time for ourselves that's
what it looks like
keeping animals growing our own plants
just living freely that's the plan
more than 1 000 people have moved from
germany to paraguay in the last year
the clone brothers want to set up a
business repairing cars like they did in
germany
they hope they can have time for their
family life outside of work
in germany both of us were employed we
both worked
the kids were in school and in
kindergarten
we hardly saw each other
sometimes for two or three days because
i had to work more to earn money
some of those who have emigrated here
are turning their back on covet
restrictions in europe
vitale fuchs who now works as a pastor
for the community in hounau explains the
high number of migrants with his
religious perspective
[Applause]
and then i found paraguay on a world map
and god said
the time has come and you will be there
and as it was said so it came to pass
i also led an online forum and my
subject was a wave of migrants to
paraguay
other members of the german community in
hohenel like inga hazu who arrived a few
months ago from the u.s are much more
forthcoming about their rejection of the
coveted measures and vaccines
all of that isn't something paraguay
should go along with she says
i decided to come here because we
noticed that through this coronavirus
situation everything was tightening up
becoming more difficult because more and
more people actually had to flee germany
austria and switzerland
they lost their jobs
and soon they won't be able to go out
shopping
and now they're announcing a vaccine
mandated
it still remains to be seen just which
coveted measures paraguay will implement
in the course of the pandemic
until then the immigrant families will
try to find their new home here
andreas zick is professor for
socialization and conflict research at
the university of bielefeld here in
germany professor thank you for joining
us on the show would you ever have
imagined
that it would get to this point where
people would actually immigrate overseas
because of covert 19 measures
no the immigration of groups especially
families is not a new pattern members of
the protests have already emigrated and
supporters live abroad they have
emigrated to reasons of conviction as
well
to escape prosecution so we have in
class we have some enclaves in canada
where former journalists offers real
estates
we know that one of the most radical
spokesmen uh is now living in turkey we
know the formation of the aspar
communities historically it's it's one
of the strategies
of the protesters and the deniers to
cope with the situation but what what is
now relevant is to observe what happens
in these colonies
is there further radicalization are they
producing propaganda so and we need to
link it to the multiple forms of protest
in the immigration it's one part the
social media offer a lot of of
possibilities to create these parallel
societies and communities
you said that it's just one part of this
protest
does it tell us something important
about the intensity of the opposition
here in germany and other countries or
is it fringe how would you look at it
no we would say that this is one element
and maybe the last step in the process
of radicalization so uh the one group is
leaving the country the other group are
further radicalizing into
uh
into a polarized ideology and into
violence when we speak about
radicalization i speak about
radicalization into ideology and
violence but this emigration is one part
it's a central element why because the
distancing the distancing to the former
system the distancing to uh to the
former networks so the distance to
traditional and majority norms and rules
is one of the most relevant elements in
this radicalization
and it's growing
we saw in the last week we saw around 50
000 people in germany in the streets we
have over 33 000 right-wingers who count
themselves among them we have network of
corona deniers
the studies by by the universities of
vienna and edinburgh estimate that
nearly nine percent of the population in
germany belong to these denominators and
it's a very heterogeneous group and the
distance is the central element
not too long ago in fact we saw a
torchlight march in front of the house
of the health minister in saxony that's
a german state do you expect to see more
violence especially as we near this
debate on a vaccine mandate in germany
there is there is a clear evidence
of further radicalization
when we define radicalization as extreme
ideologies and violence we have an
increase in public statistics in in
group based and and racist based
hate crimes we see many protests
it's not it's not that the amount of
people is increasing so
so the corona protest in
2020 that we saw huge protests but but
now it's going very much local and the
people who are now in this movement
become very extreme and the mandatory
vaccination
this the topic of monetary vaccination
was always the bridge to the center of
society so for example in spring this
year we run a representative survey in
germany and 70 in this representative
survey uh agreed to the statement
coronas
use
industry vaccination and 18
party agreed and this
this mandatory vaccination is not
perceived by the protesters as something
which is good to fight the coroner virus
but it is
a complete complete giving up of their
freedom and it's increasing the idea we
have to show resistance right now we are
losing all our rights
all right andreas sick is a professor of
socialization and conflict research at
the university of bilofeld here in
germany thank you very much
thank you very much
now it's time for you to ask and us to
answer here's a viewer question for our
science correspondent derek williams
why do i need a kovit 19 vaccine if it
doesn't prevent me from catching the
disease
i think that this question more than any
other illustrates how governments and
healthcare authorities have have really
struggled
with messaging in this pandemic and to
answer it let's go back over some of the
stuff that they could have probably
communicated better
first i think
is the fact that despite
really great efficacy numbers from
clinical trials the vaccines that we
have are not perfect silver bullets and
we should never have expected them to be
what they have so far proved to provide
is some very effective short-term
protection from serious illness and
death
caused by covid it would be great if
that protection were indefinite but but
there are indications that it might be
less long-term
than we'd hoped
one recent model based study that's
gotten some attention
posits that if sars cov2 becomes endemic
then reinfection in people who got it
once
could on average occur again in just 16
months now if correct
that obviously has implications for
durability of immune response in
vaccinated people as well
but that's just one prediction and over
the course of this pandemic
it feels like those have proven wrong a
lot more often than they've proven right
so
i would encourage people to focus more
on what we really do
know now
like the crystal clear data-based
statistics published by the cdc in the
u.s
they showed that although vaccines
haven't prevented covid19 or it's spread
completely there
unvaccinated people are still five times
more likely to test positive for the
disease
than vaccinated people are and
more importantly unvaccinated people are
10 times more likely to end up in the
hospital and 10 times more likely to die
so
does being vaccinated guarantee you
won't get coveted 19 or or maybe even
die from it no
but for at least a while maybe a long
while
vaccines certainly do
stack the deck a lot more in your favor
[Music]
you